joining me now the daily wire editor and
chief ben shapiro
back in action welcome back Ben hey
thanks how you doing
so I'm very well thank you very much so
what do you think of the president's top
three picks the people that we're
hearing so far and do you think that
this is actually the final list the
final three my guess is it probably is
the final three I'm hearing from a lot
of folks inside the administration this
is the final three which is too bad I
thought that Michael leave from Utah
would have been the best he's a senator
so he probably sails through without any
problem and you're not gonna have to
worry about his legal interpretation
since he's been on the record about
virtually every issue as a senator and
one of the big problems with how we do
these judicial selections is that you
have to draw a balance between what you
know about these nominees and what you
don't meaning that if you pick somebody
with a clear convincing record of
originalism then the left is more likely
to tank them just as they did Robert
Bork back in the 1980s if you know how
they feel about roe v wade then that's
going to lead the Senate to to shut them
down so instead what you get is a bunch
of inane questions about how much do you
like roe v wade and you have some
somebody say well you know it's
precedent and which which means nothing
I mean there are lots of cases that have
been precedent it's incredibly
irritating how we do these judicial
confirmation hearings you don't learn
anything new about these folks which is
why the vast majority of people who are
even brought up for the hearings almost
get wildly unqualified like Harriet
Miers for example ends up on the Supreme
Court yes I think just about anyone the
president picks its but it's interesting
because he goes through a different less
intuitive process with his Supreme Court
picks than he does with some of the
other decisions and I don't know if this
is because it's unfamiliar territory but
it certainly is fascinating and you're
absolutely right not only about Mike Lee
and and the more I think about it and
and Ted Cruz actually wrote a really
good piece for Fox News opinion he's
stating basically what you said which is
if you don't want surprises then you
should probably pick someone who's got a
very consistent philosophy who will
follow through on that judicial
philosophy for decades to come
Mike Lee is young he's consistent and
he's also a senator which means that if
there are Democrats or Republicans on
the fence you may have people even in
another party who would be more likely
to vote for him based on the interaction
that they've had with him he's an
affable guy but you know
apparently and I know the president had
a conversation with Mike Lee all we can
hope is that his unpredictability rears
its head once more here and that Mike
Lee is this surprise pick on Monday I
hope so too I mean the other three picks
I think all of them are fine I do have
my preference I think that Kony Barrett
would be the best followed by Catholic
and finally Cavanaugh I have the most
doubts about Cavanaugh simply because
having read many of his decisions it
seems like he's very much in the line of
of Justice Roberts which could mean too
clever by half I think he'll probably be
more solidly textualist than Roberts has
been but reminder that that when it came
to Roberts opinion Obamacare the very
basis of that opinion which suggested
that Obamacare was a tax rather than a
fine that that logic came from a
Cavanaugh opinion on the DC Circuit
Court of Appeals so yeah I've got
problems with with Kavanagh in general
he's being pushed very hard by a lot of
folks from team Bush who who knew him
way back when and are very fond of him
he's kind of the DC insider Peck I think
the Catholic or Barrett would would
probably be more solid in terms of what
originalist are looking for let's talk
about Barrett a little bit she's from
Indiana
currently serving on the second 7th US
Circuit Court of Appeals she's young
she's 46 but she does have what Diane
Feinstein personally attacked Ron is
more of an informed philosophy based on
her religion and you can see the left
will adamantly go after someone like
that knows exactly why Trump should pick
her frankly the fact that the left is
going to attack an observant Catholic
for being an observing Catholic he's
gonna win in Pennsylvania so I don't
really see the the reason and shying
away from that fight if they want to go
after a 46 year old mother of seven who
happens to be Catholic and who has
written extensively on the interaction
of Catholicism in the law she said for
example the judges in death penalty
cases who are Catholic observing
Catholics should recuse themselves
rather than ruling on death penalty
she says that abortion however is more
of a matter of public policy than the
death penalty in individual cases let
the left go after her like I don't know
why people would shy away from a fight
here the more extreme the left looks the
better it is for president Trump and
attacking in articulate excellent
candidate with it with a great story
like Amy Barrett I just don't see how
that hurts President Trump in any way
all right we'll see I don't I wouldn't
be surprised either because I think he
wants to put a woman on the high court
and I think
put some pressure on particularly some
of those female senators who are looking
to run for the presidency in in 2020
because if the future is female it would
be pretty hypocritical of them to vote
against her then thank you so much
thanks a lot